we begin this half-hour with the deadly
accident on an amusement park ride at
the Ohio State Fair some of the rides
have reopened while others are still
under inspection following Wednesday's
malfunction that killed 18 year-old
Tyler Durrell while Darrell's family is
planning to file a wrongful death suit
Adriana Diaz heard from one of the seven
other people injured when the thrill
ride broke apart these were the first
customers on the sky lift one of the few
rides to reopen at the Ohio State Fair
after Wednesday night's deadly accident
on the fast-moving fireball where
passengers and a car were flung off the
ride this is scary it's like a nightmare
come true 19 year old Hakeem Hussein and
his girlfriend Hannah were in the car
next to the one that detached it started
going faster then I started going higher
that's when they hit the ride like
blowing my whole life just flashed in
front of me like I just seen people with
our there was just people panicking
everywhere and what really bothers me is
people just wanted to have their phones
out the only known video that captured
the crash has been viewed by millions
everybody seen this video but they
weren't there it's not in their head
it's it replays over and over in my head
the couple had initially been seated in
the car that fell but were moved last
minute it still stuck in Maya cuz you
could have been one of us are you angry
about what happened yeah oh man I just
want to know what happened so do
investigators but their work could take
weeks
most rides though will return to
operation after additional inspections I
feel I did just don't care right
I feel like is just like okay let's move
on a difficult prospect for the victim
struggling with trauma for CBS this
morning Saturday Adriana Diaz Columbus